before we get started we want to let you
know that we got some tour dates we want
to invite you to take it up and come see
us for a night of unpredictable comedy
and harmonious music how does that sound
right sounded really good I might go to
the show we're gonna be singing and
talking to each other and like who knows
what else is gonna happen but it's
sometimes it involves weird get ups well
every show is different we never know
what's gonna happen we're gonna be in
Las Vegas June 21st Salt Lake City June
22nd Denver Colorado June 23rd Milwaukee
Wisconsin June 25th Indianapolis Indiana
June 26th Detroit June 27th Omaha that's
in Nebraska June 29th Minneapolis
Minnesota June 30 year and then later in
the year we're gonna be in Houston Texas
on September 4th New Orleans September
5th Birmingham on September 6
Jacksonville Florida on September 7th
Tampa Florida September 8th Albuquerque
New Mexico November 20th Phoenix Arizona
November 21st Sacramento California
November 22nd and Valley Center
California on November 23rd again these
are all the dates for the rest of 2019
and most likely for quite some time so
if you want to see us mmm now's the time
to take it up rhettandlink live.com now
on with the biscuit
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the roundtable of dim
lighting we are exploring the question
were the 20s the best years of our life
now we didn't live during the 1920s it's
like when we were 120 when we were in
our 20s was that the best time of I have
we peaked did we peak long ago question
was it I think best in Peaks are two
totally different questions you know
well it's like you're already answered I
have lots of thoughts on best and I
think it has lots of implications for
how Wow I don't want to spoil it what
about your best Peaks do are we gonna
get back into which kind of peak you're
talking about again I do need to
acknowledge that my voice is
otherworldly it's very very DJ asked I
feel like it's yeah so links
under the weather but I actually maybe
I've adapted to your voice maybe maybe
this is the new you I don't hear it
anymore I know it's like I'm still
having this head cold thing is this me
for is this permanent link well you know
what am i is it my permalink I've been
I've been in a constant state of feeling
like I'm getting what you have I mean
I've done things like I've haven't been
going to workout your consoles
everything of getting everything that's
that's called being a hypo no Andrea
no but it's I've got I have physical
symptoms you have that slight slight man
tourism but you know I think I'm gonna
be okay well when we were riding in the
car I mean if I encounter anybody I'm
like don't touch me don't touch me it's
for your own good and then we're in the
car I'm like don't touch me but I'm
touching stuff in your car and then I
noticed that I finished my coffee and I
put the coffee down and then you
adjusted the temperature gauge on your
car and whatever it is called your
temperature dial you wanted it to be
cooler my friend and I couldn't help but
notice and I did point out that as you
were touching the temperature dial your
finger was rubbing up against the my
coffee lid where my mouth goes yeah
because you had this big thermos you
take not everywhere I'm like like why
does it have nice so big why why do you
why do you why's it got it oh my
pharmacist fault
well it's your thermos is your silver
being that it was blocking the
temperature controls it's Ptolemy I
there was no way to adjust the
temperature without touching your mouth
hole on your thermos everything's bigger
with the links day I'm like Texas I'm
like Texas I mean you're just
compensating for something yeah I like
to drink coffee homie and listen I was
the gracious you never would have even
known that your finger was touching my
mouth place on my coffee mug you know he
don't say mouth place just don't use
that terminology yeah did you sanitize I
have since sanitized I wonder what you
touched on yourself after you touch my
mouth I'm actually I've gotten I don't
know I don't know if anybody's got video
evidence of
but I feel like I've gotten better at
not touching my face so you don't know
if people have video evidence of you not
doing something like that's that's not
how evidence works no yeah you don't I'm
gonna I'm gonna present reams of video
and in none of this video for the next
your movie your misunderstanding I think
ever you are not gonna see me touch
myself so if I if you have you know
approximately a decade and more
specifically about seven years of a
Daily Show of a person being themselves
in their natural environment be that
natural environment being a desk that he
shares with another man that environment
Rhett is a set how do you reckon they're
so much that it's my natural environment
my theory is and I don't listen don't do
this because I don't want anybody to do
this but my theory is that my frequency
of touching my own face has decreased
over time sure because I just feel like
I've become more conscious now I'll
touch the hair you touch that's not it
this isn't the face in fact face begins
where the hair ends they call this I
heard somebody call this like the Golden
Triangle like that he's pointing at his
mustache it was I don't know if he's
your hero he's calling it a golden Tron
your eyes your mouth and your nose but
it's basically a an ungodly a high
percentage of the crap that will make
you sick goes in through this place yeah
it's not like you're getting a cut
somewhere and getting a cold I mean it
does happen but it's going in through
the Golden Triangle I don't know if
that's the term what is the
constellation that forms this Golden
Triangle your two eyes in your mouth it
might be your two nostrils in your mouth
well it's not really a triangle that's
more of a trapezoid but your eyes have
holes your eyes are holes your eyes get
stuff too don't get eyes they get stuff
too guys I believe that I judge my face
less touch my face when I have I touched
my face yet germs how often you touch
your face a lot man I'm sick dude no no
we're not sick Lily gave me this and I
don't think she was touching my face I
probably I don't know I sometimes I'm
doing that dad thing where like wouldn't
it be funny if I acted like I was poking
you and I I probably poked my daughter
in the eye
fun of it I mean I said I'm not a dad
thing like no other dads do that just
see just speak dad speaking for other
dads hey I'm gonna poke you in the eye
that's not a thing that dads do I just
like what do you mean graze it I don't
know me don't remember doing it wasn't
me
I'm just saying I it seems weird for me
to say oh I I judge my face I took my
daughter's I just touched my face I'm
very conscious of it you did I trust my
beard is that part of the triangle I
think that's just outside of the
triangle oh the triangle he went over
the mouth and bacteria go up these hairs
and get into it is happening did we both
just get are we really caffeinated this
is a different ear biscuit I never know
what you're getting what we've had an
interesting day we've traveled we
traveled to the west side oh it's a
little bit exciting we see an other side
of Los Angeles
we ate brunch out oh yeah okay so tell
him about tell him about them the lobby
okay so I'm about to brunch yeah we had
quite a day the first was so this was
the two of us and Stevie going to a
meeting you know we're always meeting
with people tell them what the meetings
about the meeting is about making
something awesome into something even
better but different on another medium
it's about something we really want to
happen we really want you to see and
because we wrote it and we knew we want
it to be on television
I mean I don't know why we can't talk
about this all right but let's not
having fun I haven't thought about it
but you just talked about it I don't
think there's any reason not to talk if
we think about it there might be a
reason not to talk about it but I think
that's stupid well but in this
particular place that see this is the
reason that I didn't want to say what
the meeting was about because now I'm
gonna give characteristics of the lobby
of the place that we were and now people
are gonna know where it is when you tell
the people when you tell the listener
what it is we experienced then it will
be clear to everyone involved that the
people who made the decision for the
thing to be there wanted us to talk
about it so we are exonerated
that's it not exactly what I was getting
at but it's cool they have a koi pond in
their Lobby and for all if in every
other way it's a pretty nondescript
Lobby there's not anything it's not big
like sometimes you go into like I don't
know if you've ever been into the lobby
of CAA the agency the talent agency it's
not our agent that not our agent but I
have been in like not a sponsor i I do
visit other lobbies
I'm kind of a lobby connoisseur now if
you visit other agents our agents gonna
start getting shaking in the boots no no
I did what was Hey I just went to look
at the lobby and also I'm also a fully a
connoisseur any you know sort of like
the beginning of the the beginning of
going into a building whether it's a
home or a building I'm really into none
of this makes you a douche
go ahead but the this lobby was rather
unimpressive except for the fact that
they had a koi pond now I will say when
you hear a rat say they have a koi pond
I would venture to guess that you
picture like a like a foliage draped
environment with like a dark water with
some sort of sediment at the bottom like
a pond and you would be wrong
but I wouldn't blame me for it because
that's what I would picture a matter of
fact even when he's at koi pond just
then I still pictured it even though I
was there and that's not what it was
it's pretty much just a sort of a
rectangle in the middle of a floor it
was like the tile that made up the floor
then if you went down a foot and a half
and then you laid more of that same tile
it was very modern but you think the koi
need more than that
I felt I really felt sorry for the koi
well what brings a koi joy do you know
koi joy Rhett you got me I don't know I
believe that koi joy is found in just
being coy let's come back to that so
it's just a square area with
approximately four hundred and twenty
gallons of water but of course things
like koi ponds and lobbies usually
aren't the kind of thing that we cannot
experience and then not begin asking
questions to whoever's closest which
happened to be the the woman who was
manning the desk
we had a she was womaning the desk we
had a good meeting so after the meeting
we're kind of flying high and Stevie
went to the bathroom so we're just we're
just mulling around and I'm like hey two
old men with their hands in their
pockets looking at koi and I'm like hey
receptionist I didn't call her that I
wish I just was like hey you responsible
for these koi
and she said well yeah I mean if one of
them jumps out you what one of them if
one of them jumps out okay don't get
paranoid lady she was like well I said
does that happen she says yes it happens
in there very slippery and so that's
when and then she picks up the mail
like little tray the tray the cage kind
of mail tray and she's like and like I'm
like a basket like a wire mail basket
that you hold letters she's like I just
put that I put that on top of the COI
and I pushed the COI back into the koi
pond so it's not a mail tray it's the
koi pusher I got koi pusher Clark gets
her it's a coin catcher
it's a call capture that brings me joy
the weird thing she said was yes so
sometimes like big trucks will go by and
then they'll get kind of agitated and
they'll jump out wouldn't you know as if
I didn't feel sorry enough for these koi
yeah but think about a year you're just
a koi you don't know think about how
look that's why they're jumping out they
want to see what heck is driving by it's
like I don't think they just want you
know think they have ones I don't think
they have wants or joys why do you have
so much I did so much of a clear idea of
what a koi needs do you own one well we
had friends who house at for a couple
that had a bunch of koi you know this
red yeah and all the koi died because
somebody did something stupid with the
water and who was sad well none of the
koi workers they all died bingo how much
he had paid like $75,000 koi are very
expensive fish especially if they're old
and rare but she can live like 111 years
yeah some like that sometimes koi will
be left in someone's will yeah
because koi outlive the boys after the
koi pond pushing it a little too hard
the koi pond excursion a t-shirt we we
had a little bit of time before our next
appointment lots of appointments today
and so we got a little brunch and we
needed a quick bite but we wanted to be
a little bit fancy and so for the first
time yep first time ever we go to well
okay I'm not gonna say the name of it
because
it's really what makes this story funny
so we decide on this place that is a
chain restaurant that serves breakfast
and coffee well it's like Panera but
it's a little fancier
yeah you should spell it it's French
it's French well it just in French it's
the pickle bread or something like that
qu oh no le space PA e8 iin which is
that's bread in French and then another
word quot e di e in E quot I di en yes I
was close enough so there's a parking
garage underneath this particular
establishment because there's multiple
stores or restaurants so we go
downstairs
and the woman like the the parking
attendant stops us she says you're
driving she says where are you going and
I froze because I don't know how to say
this place and of course link leans over
and says la Paix quite de da la Banque
quant a done and I was like what
language was that oh well I was just so
enthusiastic because I was like oh I
know the answer to this la cuenta con no
you did not say it you did not say it in
a French accent
you said it into some other $20 and I
wasn't being funny but it was I was I
knew the answer and we needed a park and
I then said we all started laughing well
me and Stevie started laughing and you
laughed and the the parking attendant
woman sort of smiled and I said today
you know they really need a new name for
that place and she's an LP q LP koon and
that's what they call it they call it
there they call it LP q because they
don't so they don't have to say lap tank
content down oh man it feels good to say
it yeah it gives the coy joy so we have
had quite a day the menu was um very
promising and the Yelp reviews were like
there was like there were like over 700
Yelp reviews this place and it had over
4 stars like almost 400 it wasn't it
wasn't bad it's just and it wasn't good
well it wasn't it wasn't bad the menu
made me think made me get really excited
and then I just didn't feel like it
completely delivered on the menu and
also the coffee mug had no handle I
helped her so I did this chick was over
there drinking her coffee and she was
holding it like like a treasured Bowl
that you would like like served the king
oh yes monarch needs to drink of this or
something the Pope would like use
ceremoniously like that's how he was she
was bringing it to her lips and then you
know I was like why is she doing that
cuz you don't feel like that's what i
quited don't think you can grab it with
one hand what is a comment at all you
said it was pickles I know and you fell
for it
got you hold my whole day you've been
thinking a quintic dog is a pick yeah I
know but here's the thing because it was
on his plate you that's not the that's
not the kind of thing you joke about
just to be just honestly like that's the
kind of joke no no like you usually this
is your type no no you don't normally do
purposely deceptive humor like that's
the guy thing I like to tell my kids is
like you know the quality Dalton it
means pickle and so you typically know
French cuz like you I typically do yeah
that's funny we both took three years of
friend right you retained significantly
higher proportion than me Jamal a
Affleck of a French for the daily bread
the daily bread okay because quanti dawn
means day daily okay okay now you shall
not live by bread alone it doesn't mean
it bread and pickles sorry
hey and if you were to rewind and
re-experience this your biscuit
you would hear at the top Rhett gave a
shout-out to pickles the pickle bread or
something like that because he was
falling for my joke and that really gave
me joy joy but that's why you do it it's
quite a long play okay so I I feel like
I can still recommend the restaurant
just personally I would say that I think
should try it but I do think that you
should say lpq just to not embarrass
yourself unless you're French when you
go to a wrench restaurant do you order
by initials you give it a shot I know
I'm a CPK California Pizza Kitchen yeah
that's French right yes okay we're gonna
answer your questions but first we're
gonna let you know that you can look
just as tie-dyed as us I mean we just
look like we just took regular shirts
into a washing machine tie dyed in the
wool
you got your high daddy's creepy creepy
cotton candy Randy he's busting out of
my chest and you can call him and he'll
answer the question he'll answer your
question and respond to your call as
part of the mythical society content
that's being cooked up and released over
the summer every Thursday yes he will
I got this mythical Thai guy described
it that's a ran ler with a third eye the
all-seeing eye of the of the ran ler put
into a you know what don't describe it
it takes away the mystique they can see
it go see you with your third eye you
can you know what you can see both
shirts that we're wearing with your
third eye is an ironic thing but you can
only buy them a mythical dot store can't
buy things with your third eye would you
rather have a third eye or a third leg
well if the third leg isn't a euphemism
for penis already have one noted uh so I
think I go with I okay that was still
technically part of the ad
so that's mythical dot store you get for
watching the video version right you get
extra stuff let's start with a question
from Annie known as celestial link I
guess that's a reference to you link on
Twitter yeah if I weren't me I would
still devote my entire Twitter
experience to me if you could go
choice as well if you could go back in
time and bring and one current invention
with you which you would be credited for
inventing what would you bring in why so
you go back in time you can take
something with you and you will be
credited with inventing it is there a
size limitation on this time-traveling
device let's say no I would say no I
have a specific answer that then leads
to a more general and powerful answer
you know I'm gonna do it in Reverse I
have a general answer but then I have a
more specific can I just answer you want
to go first no I'm interested I do have
an answer but now I'm very intrigued I
would take back in time I would take an
hour Roby you remember the Aerobie I do
finally when we were in college we could
not be satisfied with a normal spinning
flying projectile that you can throw and
catch in the in the little grass patch
beside your apartment no we had to get
the the world's longest flying device
that can be thrown from hand to hand we
had to get the Aerobie agent quite an
amazing this OBIEE flying googliness the
flying ring they make a boomerang
version as well they make two different
sizes maybe three different size it
actually comes back to you but they do
not float they will fly a long way they
will talk in one and they will sink in
water because we've lost we've lost a
few of Roby's in some ponds and not just
ponds do they fly so far sometimes they
were just go into the woods and we would
never ever finally tell you some of the
most exhilarating experiences I think we
ever had were just getting so far from
each other that we bear that we could we
were questioning whether we were still
looking at our friend
yeah and chucking this Aerobie and then
just seeing it soar and then the thrill
of seeing that person catch it hmm I got
to hand it to us man we were good at
throwing in a row B you weren't great at
catching it though well it's not hard to
catch it we were good at catching it if
you don't catch it is pointless and it
kind of failed
it catches the wind and sort of like
hovers and you think whoa you'd think
you were about to catch it and you'd be
right here with your hands like splayed
out in front of your face and then all
of a sudden when it was like five feet
out and rapidly approaching it just it
would catch a breeze like a hawk going
over a canyon
yeah like catching thermal a thermal and
it would just it would take off and it
would go another 400 yards it felt like
it felt like it go another thirty eight
yards well I would take one you know
there's no place in Los Angeles to throw
one of these there's no open space large
enough the reason why this is top of
mind is because land oh we had we had
some unstructured time that where we
were hanging out a couple weekends ago
and I was like whatever you want to do
but let's do it
and he was and his answer immediately
was I want to go buy a tetherball that
was his answer
yeah this is a child that is used to not
having a lot of space so he was a ball
tied to a pole right that's its idea of
fun they do it they play tetherball at
at school and he fancied himself a
semi-pro now you didn't buy him when did
you hell yeah I bought him one okay I
asked him whatever he wanted I'll do it
so I called the big five and I was like
do you have tether balls and they were
like yeah of course they do so that's
pretty much what they're known for
tether balls are us I think is what they
used to be called they were like yeah we
got those so we go over there I'm like
whoa they only have one left I was like
this woman was risking a lot and just
like that snap answers like I've been
there for weeks she should have said we
only got one left you better get over
here right now I was like Lando we're
just snatch it buddy because you're
buying the one tetherball people bought
in 2019 like okay now call the factory
we got to get the we got to get another
tetherball because there I had to get it
as we were leaving with that tetherball
I saw a guy walking I was like I looked
at land I was like he's gonna be
disappointed I knew I could tell he won
I tell about but before we checked out I
went past and they had in a row be and I
was like Lando look at this and I told
him the story that I just told you way
better than a tetherball and we also
bought a $10 Aerobie they don't have the
big ones though yeah they do yep okay
you got a big one yep were you gonna
throw that well we went
the park and they had a tetherball Pole
that's why he knew he wanted to buy
tetherball oh you didn't buy the pole on
the base you just bought the ball on the
string right
find your own pole a legit Paul at the
nearby playground bring your own ball an
tether
there was no Paul at ball or tether
there it was just a pole well what is
the world coming to
I know man you can't leave a tether ball
hanging around someone's gonna take that
oh yeah just like rims taking the rims
off it lay off a souped up Civic
interesting that you would take that you
would take a inter up we back so you
think that would gain you fame and
fortune because that was kind of how I
approach this no because I think it
would be cool and people would think I
was awesome but then as I was like
making the rounds like selling tickets
for like my exhibitions of throwing the
Aerobie and whatnot and I would also
educate the people about the aerodynamic
design which would then lead to the
invention of the airplane wing because I
would go back that far in time because
you know even on the Aerobie packaging
it talks about how it achieves lift like
a wing because of the the way the lip is
designed I believe so I would actually
go back in time I was gonna just say I
was gonna take a wing of a plane with me
yeah but then the Wright brothers would
have a minute a giant frisbee and we
were still wouldn't be flying
you'd probably screw the whole thing up
you know it's like all right no Orville
well I can Trash the plan I can tell by
there's a man with a flying disc I can
tell by your ridicule that you are
tracking with my statement so would you
take I to the right break visit I would
I would pre pre live the wright brothers
i would be there at night night in the
eighteen late 1800s why don't you just
skip the Aerobie and go for plane I
already answered that okay the wow
factor I think one I think the wow
factor of inventing aviation because who
invented the Aerobie in this universe
because the plane Artie know his name
no you don't well if the plane didn't
exist then you would know his name and
that's when I'm going back in time with
anaerobic to invent flight I took a
different tack
I would good this is a difficult thing
to take back
I admit that I would take public storage
back Oh
you greedy okay so anyway you're the guy
who invented public storage is a guy
named Brad Hughes he is worth 2.2
billion dollars
gosh in 1980 he all he did was nothing
No this story goes like this my friend
he needed to store some stuff and he had
a warehouse and it was completely full
and he was like what am I gonna do and
he came up with the idea but for what he
called private storage which actually
makes a lot more sense yeah it does but
then when he took it to market he had
changed it to public storage market for
marketing reasons
he's like 85 years old The Dude's worth
to over two billion dollars because he
just came up with the idea that there
should be little cubby holes for adults
out and out in the world that you can
just pay for and no one thought of this
until the 80s I mean take that Aerobie
yeah you know I'm saying you just go
back with a I would go back with it in
fact I probably go my time machine would
probably be the storage bin and then I
would just unsheath it and come out and
be like this is not only a time machine
that's not really what's important put
your stuff in here pay a monthly fee
hand me your money now here's the other
thing because I also was thinking about
the time period you're gonna go back to
the late 1800 okay okay okay before
antibiotics I'm going back to 1980
brother like you know what I'm saying I
mean you basically have all the luxuries
of modern times there's less channels
first of all I take all my my storage
money and I just cruise around in a boat
you could come with your OB we could
toss it on I mean my boat would be so
big that you could throw a full-size
Aerobie on it but flight wouldn't exist
because I wouldn't have gone back in
time
is that okay so they're not mutually
exclusive
you could also I think public storage is
like the one thing that the majority of
people on earth when polled could agree
upon as being abhorrent
like there's just something about it
yeah but here's the thing that's like
you don't know what I'm having a
negative response to just you saying you
don't like a how about this beanie
babies that guy's worth 1.9 million
oh is this your runner-up and you all
you have to do is take a beanie baby
back and you can take that back to 1986
because that's when he invented that I
guess a chump man but it's a lot easier
to travel with your giant in it you know
so maybe I know it Finn you know when I
was in fits your brand I'd take you
talking about bean I take a storage bin
full of beanie babies back and I'd be
like I got two ideas for you fools
it'd be like well I got to get a lot of
beanie babies before I can justify this
public storage thing I think we've
answered that Shona Brown asks is it
better to be knowledgeable or better to
be ignorant in other words is ignorant
truly bliss or is it better to have
knowledge of something even if it means
it can cause pain or chaos I'd say a
corollary question which we gleaned from
Facebook from Megan Elizabeth Taylor yes
well that Megan Elizabeth Taylor would
you rather be a worried genius or a
joyful simpleton is ignorance truly
bliss how did you approach this question
in your brain I don't know your answer
of course well I took it would I rather
be the kind of play my state of being as
a person would be someone who is
knowledgeable about everything including
the things that might potentially bring
me anxiety in trouble or someone who is
just unawares of things that might bring
worry and I in and so as someone who you
know is at least somewhat knowledgeable
about enough things to bring myself
anxiety in trouble I would say that my
knee-jerk reaction is to say that I
me personally in the current state I
like I want to know I want to know
things like when we talked about the the
simulation will we know well yeah you
wanna you want you you're always opting
for knowledge and we also we talked
about are you going the other way
no no I'm talking I'm saying me this
version of me wants to know things
including like you know we talked about
this on 23andme maybe we talked about
this but you can like basically check
guess I want to know if I've got the you
know the predisposition to Parkinson's
disease right do I have these specific
genetic markers that leaves illnesses I
actually don't know if that's one
specifically I don't know what they are
but I checked all of those and looked at
all the information like as soon as I
had the opportunity to my instinct was
just to look right but in this but
that's what you're saying if you could
snap your fingers to just be a different
person like different brain personality
makeup you would opt to check your
intelligence at the door and walk in
anticipating that what you would be a
happier person well let me just say that
I don't think that I'm I'm unhappy I
don't think that I'm currently unhappy
but if I had to choose between like that
the way that the second question was
phrased worried genius or joyful
simpleton like if you're actually saying
the state of the genius is that they're
worried or the state of the simpleton is
that they're joyful I would definitely
choose joyful simpleton and I wouldn't
know what I was unaware of you know and
so I'm yeah you wouldn't know what you
don't know I'm all about that man I
would definitely choose that if I had
the choice I'm surprised by that I just
I just I just feel like that's really
incongruent I still don't get it I just
think I I'm just trying to understand
what you're saying yeah you're saying
I'm saying that meet right now if
there's something to be known if you
know this version of me it's basically
would you rather be happy instead of
knowledge knowledgeable it you burdened
with some sort of knowledge or freed to
just be happy yeah and and I understand
that this seems inconsistent with my
answer about the
the simulation the matrix and like we do
but the way I was thinking about that
was is that I actually knew that there
was a possibility that there was
something else and I could experience it
by unplugging myself from the matrix and
then experiencing the real world yeah
this year so this is like Miren I'm
literally do not not mind but in this
sense would not be it would not be able
to comprehend anything that would bring
me worry that I'm saying if the
alternative is being able to comprehend
those things and then bringing me grief
that I would choose the joyful simpleton
in if you're giving me these two choices
and I thought that's what I would choose
to but the way that I've immediately
thought about it I'm like what what are
situations that I would opt to not know
about in order to it like because when
people talk about ignorance is bliss
they're usually talking about a specific
subset of knowledge like related to
something like but then I tried to come
up with what would be that thing that's
burdensome that it would I would be
happier if I didn't know about it but
then I'm like well climate change well
no I mean it's obviously I would rather
know about that so that I can be engaged
in being part of the solution you know
even though it weighs heavily on the
mind it's actually like creeping up
constantly in the back of my mind and I
think that's I'm sure you would agree
that's a good thing you know we need
more of that more of that concern yeah
yeah just like a discomfort associated
with just the receiving of our planet
but I think but I was what it was more
personal okay so I do I have a personal
example okay if you have a relative who
they've got some indication that
something's wrong with them and then
they're they have tests done and then
they're waiting on the tests to come
back and especially being like across
the country it's not like you talked to
them every day or you see them and like
you know where were you yesterday oh I
went into the doctor it's like they kind
of have to volunteer this information
and yes this has happened and I think
engine
maybe we've talked about this but
there's an inclination to like say I'm
gonna spare you the knowledge that I'm
awaiting a test because that we think
something's wrong and it may be bad news
I'm gonna wait until I get the results
back and then I'm gonna get I'm gonna
give those to you and then I'm like well
yeah I understand that instinct I too
have that instinct it's like I don't
want to burden my mom with something
that's happening when I don't really
have answers or there's nothing
actionable like just as an example but I
said but I second guess that you know
it's as another example said I'm like I
don't actually don't think that works
because you know you're denying their
ability to love you through the unknown
and that's a and you know that happens
in life and no one should go through the
unknown where they can only wring their
own hands you want to be able to hold
hands with somebody so to speak so I
that was my personal example that didn't
work either
so I'm actually unable to come up with
anything that I would rather not know
when I approach it from that way yeah
but I guess what I'm saying is is that
you're approaching it from this point in
time sure with these life circumstances
so yeah now that you think of what can
you think of a practical example within
that way of approaching the problem
that's like actually it's better not to
know
no and I think we've talked about this
before it's like I my tendency is to
believe that knowledge about something
like data related to anything is
ultimately better knowledge is power
then then not having it then not knowing
something because you're you're gonna be
able to do something even if it's like
knowing when you're gonna die you know
if we've specifically talked about that
situation but I think I would I think I
would want to know I think I would want
to know right but so skipping back to
the other way do you feel like you know
or have known people who are more of the
there and more of an ignorant and
blissful zone I think I I think that way
well it's okay do you do you wish you
were one of those people because I think
that brings it into focus no because I'm
not
what I'm saying is this is how I
interpret the question let's just say
I'm in the ether my soul is in the ether
before I inhabit my next body I'm saying
I believe that this is how the world
works let's just say that this is how
the world works let's say it and whoever
makes the decision about what body you
end up in says red eye of course they
have the voice of Morgan Freeman which I
can't do that wasn't it an impersonation
of him but I'm just gonna this is my
voice so I'll use that he says would I'm
gonna give you a choice in this lifetime
would you like to be worried genius or
what is it joyful simpleton like those
are my choices like if I choose genius
I'm gonna be like a worried tortured
genius you know a lot like Nietzsche or
now or you're going to be a joyful
simpleton meaning you're gonna be
somebody who no one knows about you're
not gonna make any history you're not
going to accomplish anything that was
great and there's a new bar s cup ha but
you know no Forrest Gump was tortured he
was he was he was knowledgeable enough
to be tortured about jennae so I'm
talking about somebody who is just happy
but isn't made me may need other people
to take care of them I don't know what
they would might like mean I would
choose that scenario if presented with
those two options it was just like would
you rather be ignorant or knowledgeable
I would choose knowledgeable okay okay
I'm going to choose to be burdened
what's and knowledgeable let's answer
the question that we started this whole
thing off with let's pay off that title
this is from Hannah blessed sucks and
then we change it
Hannah Brooks asks your 20s are the best
years of your life mm-hmm in quotes as
if someone told her this do you agree
with this what were the best years of
your life and why the 20s is it's
interesting because I usually think of
it in terms of like middle school high
school college
out of college married married with
that's how it divided up my life married
then married with children yeah and then
I can also think about it in terms of
our career and I can like start to put
different strata in there but like the
20s that's the end of that's like the
tale into college right yeah the end of
college getting married and mostly
everything that we did before we really
became full-time youtubers I mean you
know what I'm saying it's like it was
before we had really found our calling
boy right - what we do - what we kind of
have settled into now there so it was a
bit of a strange time it was a start
figuring things out yeah and there was a
lot of there's a lot of it was high
stake peril you know it was like okay
what are we gonna do how are we gonna
you know what the heck is going on
because I feel like I'm tempted to say
the best days of my life
you know I'd be tempted to hone in on
the college years because those are some
great years mm-hmm yeah you got this
budding freedom you've got this
blossoming self-discovery
it's almost falling on you like up like
a duck like a dumptruck like you're
getting self discoveries being dumped on
you just get buried in it yeah that's
that's exhilarating well no you'd hold
your breath and then you're like trying
to trying to trying to breathe and get
out from underneath it and I think the
reason that adults will often say to
young folk you know really enjoy this
time take it you know these are the best
years of your life and they may be
talking about high school or college or
whatever I think what they're actually
saying is if I with my knowledge and
life experience and wisdom that I have
get that I have garnered in the years
that I've lived we're able to go back
yeah to high school or go back to
college oh man our just
be able to do it right this time yeah
when you're in the midst of it you don't
really understand and this is every
stage of life
well okay so let let so just to unpack
that a little bit yeah cuz basically
you're you're not saying when I look
back that was the best strata of my life
that I'm experienced and I do think I
was excited on the young is what you're
saying you're saying that if I could go
back and redo it
I could most definitely make it the best
time in my life that decade well and I
listen I'm not I'm not saying that I
didn't take advantage of it and that I
didn't take advantage of that freedom
and I didn't I specifically remember
like that first week of college if like
just coming back to my dorm room
whenever I wanted to in thinking this is
awesome having responsibility for just
myself is really awesome now at the same
time I was really not as much as you now
that I didn't even know at the time
because you didn't really talk about it
I was really concerned about my
academics I was especially a freshman
sophomore year I was like super
committed to studying and and making
good grades and I do recommend making
good grades but I think I placed a
little too much importance on that
honestly I kind of got into a little bit
better groove in my junior and senior
year and but I think yeah I do think
they were the best years of my life in
one sense are you talking about Kyle
you're not talk about 20s though you
tell my college yeah okay considering
the nature of the discovery the nature
of light the fact that I knew things
they don't have these like philosophical
conversations that you never really had
in high school and really meaningful
friendships that went beyond sort of the
typical high school friendship like true
friends and independent living and
independent experience with like being
able to go off and say we're gonna take
a trip of somewhere we're gonna go
camping together us four guys or
whatever yeah those are things that
there were so many firsts without any
parental supervision
what that it was and it's not awesome
and not just but
and our lives were different because
right out of college we got married but
like when we were talking to Stevie on
the way to that meeting she was like
heavy what was the show she asked us if
we saw it was like that it was about
dead dead to me dead to me it was like
she was like have you seen dead to me
like no I never even heard of it she's
like well it's it's a good concept I
don't know how well it was executed but
it's binge worthy and I'm like thinking
I'm you know I'm not in my twenties I
can't I don't sit around and just look
for stuff that's only that's just
borderline binge worthy
I've got like I didn't jump down
Stevie's throat this is all in my brain
I'm like I've got children and I've got
I've got like all the stuff that I'm
doing there is no better ammeter the
only baby I got I got a bedtime the only
binging that has taken place for me is
those two days that I was on my back
after the vasectomy right you can really
only get a vasectomy once I might get my
vasectomy reversed just so I could get
it again just so I can binge watch
television I mean that's literally the
only binge watching I've done in 15
years Stevie still in her twenties no
she's 31 whoops not my my
oh sorry Stevie everybody everybody here
is in their 20s in my mind okay thanks
for clarifying whoops but you know what
what's your point my point is what is my
point
my point is you like the 20s are the
time for a lot of people where it's like
they just got time to do stuff but for
us the 20s were oh we're we've been
we've thrust ourselves into marriage and
thrust is probably not the best word the
rust we've been we've been catapulted
out of college and out from under like
any sort of financial support that that
our families whatever offered and now
we're like we're trying to make this
happen I mean this was like a scrappy
time I mean it was it was nerve-racking
mm-hmm I mean I was talking about
you know we both had our engineering
jobs and we were hating them and I
wasn't realized I was hating them until
you kept insisting on how much I should
be hating it and then I was like yeah
man you're right let's figure out
something else let's get together one
night a week and come up with comedy
comedy then you know come up with a
comedy didn't get up the next morning
and get to the spreadsheets you know and
like Kristy was teaching she had a math
degree and uh she taught high school
math she taught geometry and junk like
that and she was like going crazy going
nuts just trying to figure out how to
teach high schoolers and she was only
like she was only four and a half years
older than some of her students mm-hmm
she laid down the law the first day
she's like sending people out right and
left it was like it was carnage but
paddling him
yeah she's bet she was a paddler spank
me miss neele that doesn't work she
didn't fall for that one but it you know
and so we're both like putting our heads
together and trying to figure out how
how we survive you know right but we but
you look I mean I'm house-sitting for
this couple you look out of the country
and like we're taking care of a
full-grown Weimaraner yeah but you look
back on those times with nostalgia no I
don't I do I I do
well anytime that there is that period
describe your first year of marriage
I wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy
well let me just tell you the way that
and she Krissy would say the same thing
you skip that i boy you can't I process
this in this way okay I'm 41 and I
they're especially related to like
personal health and I you know physical
and emotional health are things that it
isn't that I haven't cared about those
things but I have in the past
you know decade or so especially
probably the past
yeah decade just getting older has sort
of forced me to be like I've kind of got
to get on top of this and I'll use my
back as an example of something that has
sort of applied to a lot of different
areas of my life yeah talk about your
back problems so I never did anything
about my back and when I was in high
school I was in college never did
anything in my twenties net didn't
really do anything about them in my
early 30s but when it became like okay
this is gonna be a problem like if I
don't do something about this I'm going
to have I'll be in a wheelchair someday
like I will I will have life long I will
be I will be disabled I'm not not
kidding like my back problems were that
bad that if I didn't do something about
them I was going to be disabled and so
and I started to do the things that I
started to do and continue to do and now
it's like my back is healthier than it
was when I was in high school in terms
of the way that it feels and how often
have pain right and that's like a daily
struggle to continue to do the things
that I need to do but what I think a lot
of times I'm like man when I was 22
years old like I had a 22 year olds
spine you know what I'm saying like now
I've got probably like a 60 year old
spine because I didn't do anything all
that time and so the way I kind of
process is yes those were good times but
I've actually had and again the back is
just an example of other things like
again I just started going to therapy
last year so I it wasn't like there was
some necessarily some acute problem
there were some things that kind of came
up that led me to finally say okay yeah
I do need to go to therapy but there was
a lot of years where I didn't going
going blind was an acute problem yeah
I'm saying that was like one of the
things that okay that it wasn't going
blind you can listen to that podcast but
there was a cute problem that kind of
sent me over the edge all that to say
though is that I feel like now the thing
that I can't line up is caring about
yourself and taking actual steps to care
for yourself and
set that on top of youth like that would
be an incredible thing and maybe maybe
that doesn't happen because when you're
young you just don't feel a need to
address these things in the same way I
got all I have got all my life youth is
wasted on the young but to answer the
question are you saying that the 20s oh
maybe you're saying college either one
was the best decade of your life not who
I'm not talking like retrofitted I'm
talking about just for what it was I
think and maybe this is just a
futuristic optimistic part of me I still
always have a sense that I am entering
into the best years of my life
now you know I'm saying I'm saying like
if I didn't get much weird it didn't get
much better he was weird to me
and I in a good way it didn't get much
that much he doesn't get that much
better than what we are experienced in
my 20s in college and all those cool
memories or whatever but there are
things about me the way I thought the
way I approach life in relationships etc
that I'm glad I don't still think and do
the things that I did at the time like I
like the me that I am now more than the
me that I was then and I and I would
hope that that is a progression that
continues I hope when I'm 50 I look back
at 41 year old Rhett and I like I like
the meat now more than I like to me then
like that isn't what else is life about
right now there's this sort of sinking
feeling that eventually age will become
yeah an insurmountable problem and that
no matter what you do you're gonna die
of something you're gonna have chronic
pain or whatever maybe there's nothing I
can do about my back 20 years from now
who knows not looking forward to that
and answering those questions but I'm
just saying that yeah I've told that's
all this is Jesse I think that my
forties are gonna be the best years of
my life and then I think when entering
my 50s I'm hoping that my perspective
will be you know I think my fifties are
gonna be the best years of my life yeah
that's my hat
I've already ruled out two 20s not told
you why okay so I think for me I think
the nails
cuz I'm 40 you know I well I I don't
think it was the 30s I think I agree I
feel like we're on the well I'm in year
one you're in year two of the best
decade yeah I mean I I don't I think the
fifties won't be as good
hey what about what about got grandkids
why man I don't think that it not only
that's gonna help enough I think I think
our kids are gonna be like fifty before
they have children I think I'm gonna I
am the best I feel like I'm the best
version of myself that I've ever been
and I I want to be an even better
version of myself and I think I'm on
that journey semi aggressively and I
think that's a I think that's a big part
of well that's a big part of what makes
me satisfied is that I feel like I'm
growing and and knowing more about
myself discovering more of myself and
who I can be self realization I guess
you call that and I actually think that
there's a and I think we grew up with
this just sorry to interrupt but to add
to what you're saying I think that we
kind of had this and I feel like there's
a little bit of an American ideal here
to be like you stay the same he's the
guy that he was when he was I'm still
the same man that I was when I was 20
years old still the same man you know
I'm saying and it's like I'm like well
don't condone don't confuse it with a
southern accent I'm saying that I'm from
the south and I in many different ways
that mentality was around me okay and so
that's how I'm characterizing it alright
that's fine I'm not making a judgment
about the South I'm making a judgment
about who I was and where I come from
and what I'm saying is that I believed
that constant growth
constant change is actually a sign of
health in knots that question yeah I
mean you if it's the right kind of
change oh yeah of course change in the
right direction but I'm like what is
life if it isn't change in the right
direction like what if you're not
evolving in a certain direction you're
only dying because you are dying you
might as well be growing and living at
the same time and the idea of settling
into an a way of thinking and a way of
doing yeah soon as I reach my adulthood
and then just being that way forever no
maybe you may be us and we're
enlightened at age 21 and you just
stayed the same I'm not anywhere near
enlightened but I'm just trying to move
in that direction and so to me that's
what that's what life has become for me
is being like oh this is what it's about
it's about right here it's about this
moment it's about moving in the right
direction yeah let me let me put it this
way you know there's this there's the
phrase live your best life and I'm just
saying that to people constantly just
like strangers in the mall and you and
Joel Olsteen live your best life did he
come I think he has a book called live
your best life now okay well he added
now I'm freakin deriving a Joel Olsteen
novel not novel but is it old scenar
Osteen who cares I don't care hello
Steen what you're talking about
Olsteen ironically I didn't realize that
his book was exactly what I'm saying
which is the live your best life is
something that you're constantly doing
now I totally agree with this this is
when Joel Olsteen walks in fellas I'm so
glad that you finally figured you family
finally figured it out come to my big
old church we've got seven hundred
thousand people every Sunday I think
your mate you know it's making a
decision to say you know you tend to
focus on the future and like you put it
in terms of in the future I want I want
the future to be my best but I want this
week
or this I maybe I think is unfair to say
this day and depending on what you're
going through it might be this week or
this month you say now like Joel but I I
I think having a mentality of if I know
that I don't have plans this weekend and
I can either do I can either say well
yeah I'm gonna do nothing
I'm gonna let it come to me I feel like
for me personally more often than not
that's a mistake because it sets me up
for not living my best life now but
instead just kind of waiting for it's
like living for the weekend it's like
what about Wednesday what's my best
Wednesday now or what it if I am on the
precipice of the weekend or if I'm
thinking about it's like what's
something that I can do two sets up as
we talked about before in the context of
the kids what are some things that we
could set up loosely not grip too
tightly like the song goes that will
create the opportunity for an experience
that could be the best of that you know
the best experience I could have this
day and that may mean sitting on the
couch and binge watching whatever dead
to me is that I'm never gonna watch by
the way it's dead to you but you know
you know what I'm getting at it's like I
do feel like you talk about living your
best life now if I if you have a
mentality of like all right I've got
this I'm gonna find I'm gonna find some
enjoyment or some fill in the blank that
brings some bestest to it yeah you come
up you know gratitude mindfulness and
yeah I mean I and that that is a
challenge for me because I am I'm so
future-oriented and so I was and a lot
of people are past oriented they're like
man those are the good old days yeah and
and I look back I think you looked back
and I do the same thing and that's like
well if I would have known that I had
the back of a 20 year old I would have
done things differently I don't know
what yeah and again there's an occasion
do anything about it do anyway I don't
have I don't have a me if I sounded this
way I didn't mean to I don't have
Rhett's about it necessarily I'm just
happy that you know I'm happy that my
wife made me go to you know a certain
physical therapist who finally gave me
the right information and one thing led
to another and I'm doing things that are
helping my back live its best life now
are we doing are we just doing pop
psychology like vapid empty pop
psychology here or is it just I some I
honestly don't care if we are if we are
who cares if is it effective doesn't all
we need is love doesn't make it there
that in there
because you know we're all right we're
pretty complex creatures us humans and
our brains and we it we've got like
we've said before many times and
somebody else said it before me we've
got Stone Age hardware and we're running
modern day software on it and it leads
to a lot of different problems and I
think that you can live a life where
you're constantly stressed out and
you're there's a bunch of cortisol in
your blood it'll hit all the times
yeah or you can find some simple coping
mechanisms that help you get out of your
own head and get out of your own way
separate yourself from your thoughts and
realize that you're not you are not your
thoughts and you know find some joy in
the moment and also look to the future
with optimism and I'm not saying that we
have done this or are experts at it by
any means I think that's what I'm saying
is that we spent a lot of time we're so
focused on accomplishing things and
succeeding at things that I think a good
portion of the last couple of decades of
our lives have just been completely
consumed with trying to succeed we've
had no time to stop and think about
things like personal health and growth
in many ways because we've been so
focused on our career and just trying to
keep up with things and trying to be
good dads and good husbands and the
things and the responsibilities that we
feel like the world has put on us but I
feel like those sort of the one addition
that has happened to me in the past few
years in therapy has been the most
tangible catalyst for this it's just
this sense of working on myself
and it has made me I'd the thing I told
Jessie it was like I feel just a lot
more excited about the next chapter of
my life if I'm dividing my life in the
two halves and I'm kind of entering into
the second half I am approaching it with
a lot more excitement and not this sense
of regret about what I didn't do but
more about what I what I'm gonna get to
do and of course it could all fall apart
and I could face incredible
disappointment and tragedy and whatever
it might be but what I'm trying to do is
get to a place where the external
circumstances and the outcomes don't
affect my well-being as much and I you
know I think a factor for me in being at
this point is the fact that we've
experienced the success we have I feel
like in my brain and my heart it's
giving me the space to then explore
things that I didn't give myself
permission to do and I'm not I'm not
proud of that I think that's a lesson
learned that yeah I don't like turning
this into something prescriptive I just
like sharing our own experience so I'll
keep this on myself and say to my past
self you know I in terms of more
self-discovery and you know allowing
myself that time for myself even though
I was chasing after things and the
reason why the 20s were such a perilous
time was because we were scrap idli
trying to make things happen and it was
a feeling that there's an art to living
your best life now in the midst of those
things right we just happen to be at a
point where you know I mean everything's
not going great I mean it's not but
there's an art to that whatever life
throws at you there's still a there's
still there's still space for there to
be some bestest and you deserve to have
some bestest you know
yeah so I'll leave it at that but I
think it's so I'm gonna say not the 20
to the forties the forties the 40 the
forties and Beyond are the best years of
our lives and with that best years of
lives I'm gonna leave you with a wreck
right maybe Rick baby 1 2 3 4 wreck baby
maybe 1 it's a it's a book that's made a
big difference in my life
Joel Osteen live your best life
yeah I'd plan on recommending this no I
can't say that I would recommend that
book I don't know Joel haven't read the
book good for you if you've read it and
you got something out of it but what I
actually was planning on recommending
something else but I will do I'm gonna
recommend something I recommend it
before but I'm gonna say it again
therapy did you just change your answer
yeah no I actually had something else
but I can save it because it was
completely unrelated and I can use it
for another time I've talked about it
before but I know that I thought that
there was a stigma attached to therapy
because I thought that you had to have
an acute mental issue in order to go to
therapy but to me if you want to use the
analogy of a car I think that the idea
of like I don't take my car in man until
I got a problem you know what I'm saying
man but I think if you want your car to
continue to run clean you want it to be
trouble-free you take it in for the
scheduled maintenance man and the
scheduled maintenance gives my daughter
on the view or whatever she's on and the
scheduled the scheduled maintenance of
your body there's a there's an
interesting dichotomy that somehow in
our culture we have this huge mind-body
split and we like yeah I've got a
problem with my knee that's something I
can talk to my boys about I know that
I'm characterizing everyone who's
ignorant is with a southern accent and
I'm just doing it because that's where
I'm from I just think that was George
Bush those those are the kinds of
accents that I do but
trust me I'm a redneck your heart so
I've got nothing against that but the
idea that you can talk freely about your
physical problems but when you get to
talking about mental problems that
suddenly this isn't something you can
share with a friend this is something
that you're gonna be judged for that's
an unfortunate side effect of something
that's gone wrong with this particular
society and you say mental you mean I
mean a most mental and emotional types
and I think that I wish I had discovered
it earlier and I highly recommend it and
you know I know that for a lot of people
cost is an issue and I don't know what
the solution is for that I know at one
point we recommended better health but
then you couldn't recommend better
health because there was some
controversy around the people that I
don't know even know what the deal was
but they're not a sponsor anymore but I
I don't know what the the alternatives
are for sort of low cost you know mental
help mental health help but I'll just
say that I think they have clarified
their their the qualifications of the
people and that clears some things up
and they also refined what types of
issues that they're tackling okay so our
own research on that I do not I'm not
going to say that it is an illegitimate
resource I've gotta encourage people to
check that out on their own and yeah so
I'm just saying that do your own
research to find out where affordable
you can get some affordable therapy but
I just I would just say that I believe
that it's a priority and there's
probably some things that you're
spending money on that may not be as
important and so you know do what you
can to find that help alright it's
important it wasn't a book it wasn't an
album but that was pretty good yeah
pretty good all right hashtag ear
biscuits keep talking at us and we
always enjoy hearing your feedback and
also we enjoy hearing if you introduce
other people to these conversations hey
you should you should check out ear
biscuits these guys are filling the
blank with whatever you think will
resonate with them make it up it lie to
them if you need to just fabricate all
marketing hire thing all marketing is
lying
so I just lean into it yeah yes yes we
need it if you think you're if you think
you're you think your friend would be
more into two women just say it's two
women and they're really funny or
whatever it'll take a few episodes for
them to figure it out but hopefully
they'll be hooked by then
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]